[Music]
it makes me more thankful in general for
sure 2017 was quite a year for Jimmy
Kimmel he hosted the Oscars to rave
reviews in February and less than two
months later in April
his wife Molly gave birth to their son
Billy who had an emergency open heart
surgery just three days after he was
born
now Kimmel is back to host the big show
on Sunday this time with a new
perspective to be honest it minimizes
the importance of something like this
which last year seemed to me to be the
most important thing in the world and
then you get this a reminder that this
is even close to the most important
thing in the world and you reminded of
that every day when you go home so in a
way yes it definitely has made me
appreciate my life more it also puts
things in perspective ET sat down with a
late-night host on Wednesday in LA he
teased what to expect did you have any
special requests for the show itself yep
more snacks in my dressing room would be
nice I mean it really was I mean enough
with the SunChips but now I don't have
meant much in the way a special request
I can go with the flow it's not my show
I'm just hosting it and I just hoping to
be funny keep the show moving and have
some stuff that maybe people will talk
about the next day
[Music]